jason reza giorgani
thank you for coming on the show
pleasure to be with you alan thanks for
the invitation
i'm so excited for this you're very
polymathic
that's definitely a great storyteller an
eloquent speaker
excellent author of six plus
books now and
founder of the prometheus movement
which is exciting to talk about i'm
looking forward to that my friend david
johnson
actually dj he pointed me out to you
and he was like check him out and i was
like he's
great and then i requested you on
email and facebook and you were like
my fiance in the seam is in la i'm here
for several months
we can make this work and boom here we
are
you know the first thing that jumped out
at me when you messaged me was that you
used the name
atlas my first book was prometheus
so that's an interesting synchronousy
why why do you use atlas
why did you pick that as your avatar
yeah that's a perfect way to ask it why
pick that as the avatar
well it picks me you know well yeah i
understand that
yeah yeah and then it really resonates
because
and i noticed that as well with
prometheus and atlas was that
in a sense not only taking on
such a great burden of
maximizing human potential but also
of having a cartography for who we
are why we're here where we're going
that type of thing
yeah well you know in prometheus and
atlas i use
atlas as an archetypal symbol
for a kind of post paradigmatic science
with the idea being that if we pay
proper attention to the kind of data
that parapsychologists have been
amassing for well over a century now
what's at stake isn't simply another
scientific revolution like the
copernican or the darwinian revolution
or even the quantum revolution
what's at stake is a scientific
revolution
that would make us aware for the first
time of the way in which our thinking is
constrained by paradigms or dogmatic
frameworks so when you're dealing with
psychical research
um and that becomes a basis for
revolutionizing
uh various fields of science you know
of science and technological innovation
um there is
the potential there to become conscious
of
the ways in which the mind is
subconsciously or unconsciously
constrained by certain
presuppositions that uh
delimit or or constrain what theories
are even possible in the first place
right so atlas to me
is a vision of a post-paradigmatic
science where we can work with different
atlases of the world
understanding that our scientific
theories aren't
mirroring nature they're not mirrors
that
are intended to provide us with an
adequate representation of nature where
if we polish the mirror
you know rigorously enough we'll get a
perfect reflection of the structures in
the universe
rather our scientific
theories are really models and you know
atlas is also a term for a model like
the atlas of the human body in medical
science
so atlas to me is is uh post
paradigmatic science where we can work
simultaneously
with theoretical frameworks that appear
to be contradictory
but that we recognize ultimately only
serve a practical purpose
beautiful that's that synthesis approach
that
you and i both prioritize
and that in very many ways it
seems like that next
step that we are taking with our
technologies
is enabling those blind spots
to be very clearly seen around well
which cognitive biases do i actually
have
and other things around
maximizing our both individual and
collective
potential and i love the way that you
explain
the way of how do you take something
that
seems to be the silos that exist
in the like the analogy that we like
making here is
for the
an organism you take the human body the
heart and the gut
and the brain and the liver and pancreas
and all these systems have to
have a strong amount of inter-body
communication
in order for it to function and on a
similar level we have these silos right
now happening between the tech giants in
the united states
the geopolitical climate the us and
china and saudi arabia and russia and
all these geopolitical entities as well
and the tech conglomerates in china as
well and so
there's the the data is extremely siloed
it's extremely asymmetric
between the users and the corporations
and so
in a sense there's a
de-siloification in a decentralization
and a sovereignty that happens at the
level of
of the individual which then
enables like you say these different
like my
map of my data on a social media
platform
to also be able to talk to the map of my
data of my
consumer purchase history that's right
and stuff like that
and at the biological level as well i
have
this youthful homeostatic capacity of an
18 year old i remember
10 years ago i could just do
everything and now i'm 28 and i'm like
man this
back thing is crazy and so at a
biometric level as well
right the cartography of the human atlas
those biometrics as well to be able to
speak with
all these other aspects to our lives
these maps interweaving yeah you know
you mentioned sovereignty the kind of
sovereignty that comes with
being able to flip between different
maps of the world right
and be more conscious of the
presuppositions that
subconsciously constrained your
theorization before that
right um and i also use atlas as a
symbol of sovereignty and prometheus and
atlas because of course atlas
was the king of atlantis atlantis means
the realm of atlas
uh in plato's you know writings about
atlantis
and so um the idea of atlas as a
sovereign
not necessarily as a king of a political
realm but as the sovereign individual
who by being conscious
and aware and no longer subconsciously
constrained by certain presuppositions
is
bearing the burden of awareness and
enlightenment
and becoming a sovereign individual
right who
is capable of working with different
atlases
in order to maximize his evolutionary
potential
yes so well said oh
i love it giving even more meaning
to what is
atlas from for me as well it's just
thank you for that that's a super
valuable part of the
intro of the convo
a place where you speak
really eloquently is
history which is very interesting
there's a lot of
beauty to the way that
we are able to be present right here
right now a hundred billion or so humans
lived and died before us today to
have the abundance that we have today
and the gratitude that we can have for
that is
extremely crucial the running water the
abundant food
the clean air the electricity education
healthcare economics all these things
yet we had
a hundred million plus deaths that
happened in the 20th century
um 70 million is a consequence of war i
believe
and so
there's a lot to unpack about
the if we take this from the perspective
of
the way that a simulation emerges
because at any point in the tree of
possibilities
that
the united kingdom
and europe coming to the north america
if that didn't happen what would be the
difference on a planetary level
a change in any of these major wars
could have just completely altered the
way that
our planet is
and we like to hypothesize that those
are all already running
in all the multiverses at the same time
as this one
so the question would be something like
how do you see in our
historical evolution the geopolitical
interplays that have led us to the point
where we're at today
and what's been some of the most key
variables
in that process as well as some of the
most unseen
things behind the veil like you've
talked about operation paperclip and
many of these other things yes
okay first of all
it's not clear how different our history
or rather not our history but
how different the structure of our world
would be if one or another
colonial conquest had or hadn't taken
place
and one reason why a very advanced
civilization a civilization
which from our perspective would be
archantic or angelic or
demonic one of the reasons why they
would
run a global simulation would be to
develop a science of history
and by science of history i mean you
would want to see how much stayed the
same
depending on the variables that you
changed right i mean
we might be surprised at how much of the
world would be the same
if let's say the french had conquered
north america rather than the british
right they made an attempt after all
um or you know what it would be like if
uh the roman empire had never fallen to
the barbarians
whatever um a lot might be the same we
don't know
and one of the reasons why you would run
a global simulation
is to start to see the parallels between
alternate histories and develop
uh predictive laws of social evolution
okay so um as
hard as it is for us to take the idea
that there are programmers sitting up
there and watching the atrocities of the
second world war
unfold right if we approach it from out
of the mindset
of a social psychologist we might begin
to understand
why someone would want to run a
simulation like that
um maybe the things that they learn
about
law like developments in history from
within this simulation are you know
um are uh data that they're going to
apply
to social engineering in their own world
okay
so it's an open question how much of our
world would be the same
uh in terms of our infrastructure our
quality of life and so forth if one or
another civilization
hadn't fallen or if one or another
conquest hadn't taken place
now if you ask me you know what the key
turning points in our history have been
and the ways in which they relate to the
question of the esoteric or the occult
uh what's been hidden you know um and
and uh you know what transpires behind
the veil or behind the curtain of
our recorded history i would have to say
that
uh it's fairly clear to me that the
major turning points in our recorded
history
were the abrahamic revelations that
there is a qualitative distinction
between pagan religions whether it's
greek paganism the olympian pantheon
or hindu paganism or mithraism
there's a qualitative distinction
between the pagan religions
and religions based on divine revelation
of a scripture
whether that's judaism christianity or
islam and so i would say that the key
turning points
in our history our version of the
simulation
are those moments when the
um i don't want to say necessarily the
fate of a civilization but
the developmental trajectory of a major
civilization
was altered by a purported religious
revelation
so and this isn't necessarily you know
uh
the life time and the teachings of
christ
but the moment 300 years later when the
council of nicaea
canonized christianity and ultimately
institutionalized it as a theocratic
basis
for a reorganization of the roman empire
so that would certainly be one
major um fork in the road
one major watershed moment in
our recorded history another would be
the uh conquest and um
forced conversion of the sasanyan
persian empire to islam
uh interesting that you picked this one
as the second one
yeah well it's it's certainly the second
most significant one after the
christianization of the roman empire
because
the thing uh that's lost on a lot of
westerners is that
you know plato aristotle much of the
intellectual heritage of classical
antiquity the same kinds of books that
were in the library of alexandria when
bishop carroll and you know early
christians torched the library of
alexandria
the same treasure troves of knowledge
that were
in places like alexandria and corinth
and other cities of the classical roman
empire were also in iran
up to the moment when the arab muslims
conquered iran
around 650 a.d so that whole
flowering of the renaissance and the
industrial revolution
which took a thousand years to take
place in europe
after the christianization of rome that
development could have taken place in
iran as early as
you know 600 700 a.d had it not been
for this traumatic rupture on account of
the arab muslim conquest of iran and the
collapse of the sassanid
empire and again this represents a
moment when
a pagan culture was radically
transformed and re-engineered by a
purported religious revelation
so i would say that these are the the
moments of greatest divergence and
you know the the watershed um the
watershed moments in our recorded
history
where if there are programmers behind
the curtain
this is uh this is the moment at which
they're altering significant variables
to see how the developmental trajectory
of a society
can be you know altered
it was interesting when you said that
the
takeaway of a simulation
at a civilizational emergence level
could be something like the
ways that the dynamics interplay between
the sovereign agents there that then
evolve
some sort of social rules and laws
around their own sovereignty and the way
that their cultural dynamics work
that was interesting because you run
that a trillion
or more times and then you begin finding
a meta pattern and there's a bunch of
cool things
there and then it was also interesting
when you said that the
you know zoroaster is such a fascinating
the axial age in general is such a
fascinating
sort of moment and of course there's the
the practices of the
indus valley especially that run
even prior to that
where there's an investigation inward is
basically the essence
an investigation into what is the nature
of consciousness
and then that leads to an also an answer
of what is the nature of reality
is this consciousness eternal is it
infinite
lee being colored by these creation
designs and these realities
and is that god is that what god is is
that what sources is that what
we are and so the profundity of those
revelations
were in many ways such a pivotal moment
and so
it makes sense that you sort of kind of
also
mention that yet at the same time the
the abrahamics have this
profound corpus of stories again like
the parable of the prodigal son is such
a
one that's so deeply relevant here where
rather than seeking for
happiness externally that we
hit a breaking point and we turn inward
and we understand that the well of honey
is actually located under the rock of
that contracted egoic
separate entity
so let's play there
would you say that the revelations
around
the mystic traditions
mysticism being union with god or union
with the absolute
would you say that these perennial
wisdoms across the mystic traditions
would you say that those types of
inquiries
and revelations
were the
prime pivotal moments
on the trajectory of a civilization yeah
before i can even begin to answer that
we have to clarify a few things
yes uh first of all when you say
perennial moments of revelation it seems
to me and i may be hearing this
mistakenly
that you're conflating the sages of what
you described as the axial age coming
out of
carl jasper's analysis of that whole
period of history that you're conflating
the sages of the so-called axial age
like
lao tzu zarathustra i don't know
heraclitus and some of the other greek
sages
um buddha that you're conflating those
with
the prophets who brought religious
revelations is that am i hearing you
correctly and that you're classifying
all of these as mystical revelations of
some kind
when i say perennial
mystic traditions
my understanding you're thinking about
like christian mysticism
sufism and you're putting those on a
level with the sages of the axial age
right yeah
okay here here's why i asked okay here's
why and i know i'd also like to say that
when we hear things like
i and my father are one yeah yeah yeah
it's also the same thing colored
differently
i get you i get you yeah i get you i
have a serious problem with this
way of thinking oh interesting okay okay
so
the point i was trying to make earlier
when you asked me about if if we are to
think about our history as a simulation
what are the watershed moments where are
the variables being significantly
altered and i suggested that it's the
moments when the
religious revelations take place
particularly judeo-christianity and
islam
what i meant was that the pagan cultures
uh into which these revelations were
injected
were qualitatively different not just in
terms of their
social organization but also in terms of
what counted for wisdom
and you know a mystical path to
enlightenment
okay so i see what you've described as
and i'll get to this question of the
axial age in a second okay
but in a moment but what you described
as the sages of the axial age
heraclitus buddha zarathustra
i see them as
seeking wisdom through the power of
their own intellect and through
the direct experience that they
accumulated in their lives
and offering that experience up
to seekers through their writings okay
so that whoever has the inclination to
devote themselves to intellectual
cultivation can pursue that path
toward enlightenment i think that's
generally characteristic
of uh pagan mystical traditions
whether they're in greece or in india
revelation is based on heavenly
authority
it it is based on a moral code
uh that is disclosed from on high with
the seal of divine authority
and these types of revelations
really injected themselves into
and you know vectored themselves into
and re-engineered civilization on a
large scale at two points
one with the judeo-christian takeover of
rome and the other with the muslim
takeover of the persian empire
okay and i would push back against your
characterization and say that
even the kindness has led to where we're
at today
well it led to a thousand years of
darkness and had it not been for that in
my view we'd have cities on mars right
now
so uh i would say that
now the case of judeo-christianity and
islam are significantly different from
one another
i would say that even the type of
mysticism that you see in the gospels
and particularly in the gospel of john
is a uh crypto pagan
form of mysticism let me give you
a a brief argument for why that might be
the case
if you look at about 150 years after the
time of
uh 150 a.d
okay 150 years after jesus was
supposedly born
you see that all these statues are
cropping up around the roman empire of a
certain
polonius of tiana and their stories
being promulgated about this man's life
and ultimately a very famous biography
of a polonius of tiana
is written by a prominent roman author
called philostratus
and the life of this apollonius of tiana
a sage from syria who spent most of his
life in judea
and was ultimately almost crucified
and barely escaped with his life the
miracles he performed
the teachings that he uh expounded in
judea
are an almost exact parallel for major
elements in the life of jesus
and in particular the pythagorean
hermetic teaching of apollonius of tiana
almost perfectly mirrors the mystical
elements of the gospel of john and of
the gnostic gospels
so you really have to wonder how much of
the mystical element even of the gospels
when they were canonized you know in the
period of
the nicene councils and so forth comes
from a pythagorean hermetic
uh pagan mystical tradition so even in
its formative stages
whatever constituted the christian
revelation
whatever was being injected into the uh
you know to recode the roman empire
right um
was amalgamated with pre-existing pagan
mysticism in the case of islam
the muhammad in revelation which you see
in the quran which you see in the hadith
and the traditions attributed to
muhammad
is very lacking in any kind of mysticism
that you could
um that you could analogize to tatvam
asi to the spirit of the upanishads and
so forth it's very lacking
whereas is overflowing with it
and you know i've studied this in depth
at length and in depth and my conclusion
is
that sufism is uh it's
it's crypto mithraic it's kryptos or
austrian it's an attempt to preserve
the pagan spirituality of the persian
empire
in the face of a very draconian
authoritarian
religious revelation a very
inquisitorial religious revelation
so i would say that
it's for good reason that the sufi sages
were persecuted
and in many cases martyred as heretics
by the islamic authorities
they were uh actually perverting
the revelation uh that was injected into
the sassanid persian empire
so you have to be very careful in
conflating
these revelations you know by
jesus or muhammad with the wisdom of the
sages of the so-called axial age
and then i think you have to be very
careful about the axial age
carl jaspers framed the concept of the
axial age he was a student of martin
heidegger
and his idea was that you had all these
stages crop up in different parts of the
world
basically with the same you know
expressing the same message of
enlightenment
and more or less the same path to wisdom
right in the vernacular of their culture
but that there is a perennial wisdom
that they are all
uh branches of and expressions of
quasi-independent expressions of
and i i think that this thesis doesn't
hold water when you really study history
if you look at the so-called axial age
you're talking about the age of the
academic persian empire
and these places were not geographically
distinct from one another
they were all on the margins of the very
same empire
that was interconnected with the most
magnificent royal road system built in
history until the time of the romans
uh so you know the greeks and the
indians had lots of commerce and
interaction with one another and it's
not surprising that
some of the same ideas um that you see
in the fragments of heraclitus are also
in the upanishads and vice versa i even
argue
in my book iranian leviathan that
this figure we call lao tzu was actually
a wandering scythian sage
who at one point was connected to the
persian royal court
and that you know he winds up being
exiled to northern india
and then ultimately sojourning uh in
northwestern china
and becomes the basis for the formation
of this character of
laotzu and i draw comparisons between
his teaching and uh you know the wisdom
and the fragments of heraclitus
and point to their common origin in
archaic iranian thought
so you know you got to look at the
context of the accommodate persian
empire which connected
all of these places where you have these
sages arise and promulgate these
teachings
and then i think when you do that this
thesis of perennialism becomes
a little less compelling which is not to
say that there isn't some transcendent
wisdom that these people were all
engaged with but there's also a lot of
very real sociological
and and cultural um connection there
connectivity there
if i understand
correctly would it be that
your understanding is that rather than
with my understanding it's something
like
the mystic traditions
across the planet are
all
there's many analogies to use one of
them is they are
all ice cream and that they are
different
flavors of ice cream another one is that
they are all faces or paths
that are all pointing to the same one
end
and so if my understanding is correctly
that sort of perennial
philosophy and wisdom
doesn't account so much for you
you see the revelation
in the abrahamic tradition as
what ended up creating
the modern civilization that we have
downstream
uh i i see it as responsible for a lot
of the dysfunction of our modern
civilization a lot of it's schizophrenia
because it disrupted organic
and um
organic and
personal paths to enlightenment
that you found in various pagan cultures
so like for example the teaching of
buddha in northern india is entirely
geared on personal cultivation and on an
individual path toward enlightenment
the same thing was being taught in
alexandria yet you have the noble
eightfold path that is very similar to
the ten commandments
i would totally reject that i would
categorically reject that
first of all if you look in the book of
exodus
and remember the book of leviticus
follows the book of exodus
okay and the commandments as they're
presented in exodus
are then mirrored in leviticus and
expanded upon
and when you look at exodus and
leviticus together what you see
is that this notion of there being ten
commandments
is a later historical construction there
are many more than ten commandments
or if you're familiar with confucius's
four books five classics
there's also lots and the analects and
whatnot on morality and on these styles
of
wisdom it's very perennial in a sense
i think it's fair to to draw a
comparison between confucius and buddha
and to sit down and
and show where these thinkers overlap
and where they significantly diverge
and okay in the part of iranian
leviathan where i talk about lotsu and
buddha
and i argue that these are actually the
same figure yeah
that'll throw you for a trip but i argue
that gotama was actually
that low to the legend of lotsu is based
on gautama sojourning in central asia in
any case
it's been the the case that historically
both taoism and buddhism have clashed
in a very violent way with confucianism
in china
both taoism and buddhism were relegated
to an extreme
minority fringe phenomenon in chinese
cultural history because of the
institutional dominance of confucianism
which saw
both of these uh wisdom traditions
as extremely dangerous and destabilizing
heresies
okay so from the chinese confucianist
perspective
certainly neither taoism nor buddhism
were compatible with confucianism in
fact they were seen as grave threats to
society
that's one thing then if you try to take
any of these and compare them to the ten
commandments i say hold your horses
okay because i mean we're dealing with
the most diametrically opposed
approaches
to uh the cultivation of the human
character
that's imaginable the commandments and
again they're not ten there are many of
them and they include commandments about
how to treat your slaves
since slavery is institutionalized in
the bible particularly in exodus and in
leviticus there are all kinds of
commandments that have to do with you
know
terrible treatment of women in society
and how to properly treat your slaves
and
and all kinds of other things that are
inimical to any kind of
cultivation of wisdom right and then
this framing of them as ten
is is really uh you know it's a
retrospective
historical revisionism but even if there
were ten commandments their commandments
that
come from down you know come down from
on high with the seal of authority
of the one true god uh and consequently
they're fundamentally different in their
nature from precepts that are being
presented by a sage
as constructive guidance on the path to
enlightenment these to me are
as divergent as as anything fair
it's fascinating to me to hear
you hit the tennis ball back like this
and it's really refreshing because it's
a
perspective that in many ways rather
than finding the
similarities is finding those
differences
and making those clear and i think
that's a really important perspective to
also share
it's important especially if you're
seeking the similarities
right i mean if you really want to
identify
commonalities um of a psychological
nature of a psychical nature uh
in terms of the human quest for
enlightenment
let's say the humanoid quest for
enlightenment then you have to
understand the differences first
right and the fact of the matter is that
we don't even have a data set
that's broad enough to be able to even
properly ask the question of whether
there's a perennial
wisdom we would need to look at vulcan
philosophy we would need to look at
you know the philosophy of i don't know
people on the wookie planet
okay we need a cosmic scope
for empirical research yeah and on that
basis we could then determine
whether there's a convergent evolution
of consciousness in the cosmos
where you know something like the
humanoid form of
organization is a teleology
is a kind of goal directedness built
into nature
and whether because the humanoid form
is common across the cosmos as a higher
revolutionary form
whether it's the case that all life is
tending toward
a single endpoint of the evolution of
consciousness an attractor yeah that now
that may be the case
uh but you know we don't know
really and that's the empirical mindset
that's a scientific mindset that's
characteristic i think a definitive of
western civilization
and i think that you know it's been a
grave sin
for modern scientists to marginalize
you know the data of psychical research
and not to take the occult seriously as
a dimension of human experience and and
so forth
but on the other hand i see that kind of
radical commitment to empiricism as a
great strength
of the western attitude as compared to
say
you know eastern paths toward
enlightenment
yeah and that's ultimately what we
share on the show a lot which is the
synthesis
of again very broadly speaking the east
and the west
or very broadly speaking spirituality
and science or very broadly speaking
indigeneity and modernity
there's many different ways to sort of
split into two and then say
ah drain the dirty bath water
uplift the clean baby and bring them
together into one
it seems as though even i really
appreciate
the cosmic perspective of having an n
that's greater than one
being really valuable here in terms of
oh let's analyze
other secretions of life on
celestial bodies orbiting stars
that then gain self-awareness and pierce
the veil and
understand their metaphysics and then
see if it
correlates with ours
it's good that's that's solid that's
really valuable it is
and at the same time in a sense we
are a micro version of that where you
have all of these little cultures
that have blossomed across the planet
that are all
in what appears to be pointing towards
the same mountaintop
and even the word in the sense the words
themselves are like
god or dao or brahman
or even
the universal wave function like
in to a certain extent it's seems to be
a source or infinity or eternity
as much as these word clouds have
different
descriptors around these individual
words
the word clouds also
have a tremendous amount of overlap and
similarity and that seems to be the
mountaintop
that it is pointing towards and i i do
agree that there is this sort of
there's a deep style of what's called
self-inquiry or self-abiding to
what is thought of as the witness or the
observer or the i
am or the self which is in a sense the
eye of god
that we share that is being colored
by different experience and that's sort
of what
much of the perennial wisdom points
towards and yet it also points towards
things like
this being a appearance
this being a dream this being an
illusion
and that the
physicalism the form
as quantum mechanics is sharing with us
now
all is no thing all is energy
and so it's becoming more and more clear
that what we do
at night a third of our lives
we spend a chunk of that dreaming
taking we simulate a reality take the
first person perspective
into it jason for a period of time
becomes paul in
the streets of london
in this dream and he's having some
tea enjoying his time there and then all
of a sudden you wake up and you wonder
well that wasn't real
that was a dream and so this
simultaneously whether it's god's source
infinity eternity the dao brahman what
have you as an absolute
being a dreamt creation design
an immersion into it
and coloring that awareness or
consciousness with experience
how do you feel about that
well um i think the refraction of the
human personality
into the various personas that we assume
in dream states and that you know we
interact within dream states
could be a metaphor for how our reality
is structured i mean it could be that
you know it's almost cliche at this
point we're all part of god's dream
you know we're all avatars of some kind
of a divine consciousness
um and you know our world uh
is not does not have an ontological
status that's fundamentally different
from that of a dream
okay that it's a kind of intersubjective
dream state
uh like in the film inception for
example
and you know i agree with you it's a
fascinating um phenomenon to see
how your consciousness individuates
itself
uh and gives life to these different
personas
in the dream state right um
especially if you've ever had the
experience as i have
of having the same dream continue
serially on multiple nights where it's
almost like you're going into an
alternate reality
and you know there are these
personalities there that seem to have a
life of their own right
and yet they're your own psyche uh you
know sort of
refracting itself in various ways sure i
mean
that could be a an analogy for how
reality as a whole
whatever reality capital r is how you
know as the cosmos as the whole
functions that's possible
again we don't know um
something that i wanted to say in
response to to uh
you know your remarks a little bit a
little while back
about um the mind of god
you know within ourselves in other words
the microcosm
that is reflecting the macrocosm right
um the god within us as it were right
uh i'll throw this out there and you
know we can unpack it if you want to
uh if not you know we could just leave
it out there
but i would
i would um be so bold as to claim
that the only way
that we are a microcosm of some kind of
macrocosmic
consciousness is if
there is a convergent evolution of
consciousness in the cosmos
and some kind of super consciousness
from the future
is engaged in a dynamic relationship
with us
to me that's the only empirically
sensible way
to frame the claim that our minds are a
microcosm of some kind of macrocosm
but here's the problem if that's how you
want to characterize relationship
between the microcosm and the macrocosm
the last thing that god wants is
perennialism
because god is quote god
unquote is a super consciousness at the
end of history
which is running out of the future okay
and so what god needs from us
is a broadening of the field of
potential experience
so god would want further
differentiation and increasing
complexity
and therefore this macrocosmic
consciousness
at the end of history would be trying to
introduce dissonance and conflict and
differentiation
so as to see what types of new forms and
structures might arise
because that being is desperately in
need of some kind of change
okay that being would be facing suicidal
nihilism
and in that case we would have to save
god
okay god would need us to save her
from suicidal despair
and the last thing that that kind of a
divine consciousness wants is
perennialism which is going to
level everything and try to make
everything seem as homogeneous as
possible
that god would want discord and
dynamic creative strife i feel like it's
a perfect segue
into than one of the topics that we
definitely wanted to touch on
so it may be that
as consciousness
pierces the veil and
awakens to the nature of its reality
that there is a perennial wisdom that
emerges
there and what
science and technology and engineering
are doing is that they are
what appears to be like
a complex system that's evolving towards
an attractor
it's what it seems like in a very
decentralized
unilinear orthogenic style way
are building towards the metaverse the
synthesis
of artificial general intelligence bio
and neurotechnology like
neural links the indistinguishable
virtual realities
immersing ourselves into those and so it
may be that
as consciousness awakens and pierces its
veil
and recognizes its true nature there's a
perennialism around that
but then as we enter into what appears
to be this
you know this 21st century these next
100 years
are building out this metaverse which is
what enables that
radical differentiation
that you speak of which is all of these
indistinguishable virtual worlds
that then as john smart says in the
transcension hypothesis
that we go inward well we go inward and
outward at the same time with the
cosmic exploration as well as the
transcension
inward and that that is a hypothesis
and how do you feel about the
differentiation being there at the
metaverse level
yeah so i i see these as inextricable
phenomena
um you know in prometheus and atlas
and world state of emergency i talk
about respectively
the spectral revolution what i call the
spectral revolution
the scientific revolution that awaits us
um through a serious recognition of the
data
amassed by power psychology and then in
world state of emergency i talk about
the technological singularity the
convergent advancement
of various uh you know singularity level
technologies
and then in prometheus i synthesize
these two and and talk about them in a
comparative way
and make the argument that the
technological singularity will force us
to go through the spectral revolution
because
you know as materialistic as these
various um
technological research programs appear
to be
whether it's genetic engineering or the
attempt to develop artificial general
intelligence
the fact is that if you know phenomena
like what rupert sheldrake calls morphic
resonance and biology are real
or if telepathy and uh psychokinesis are
real
genetic engineering researchers and ai
researchers are going to run into these
phenomena as
bottlenecks in their r d programs
okay so there's gonna be a point past
which
it is no longer possible for mainstream
scientific researchers
to marginalize this type of data
they're going to encounter it as an
engineering bottleneck
and so i i really wouldn't draw
any legitimate distinction between
the full flowering of the technological
singularity
and um a society where
uh our latent psychic abilities and our
spiritual potential if you want to put
it that way is fully recognized
i mean these are ultimately going to be
inextricable from one another
uh we we cannot successfully navigate
the technological singularity
without also going through what i call
the spectral revolution
and vice versa and this is my problem
with a lot of
uh how can i put it overly
transcendental eastern paths to
enlightenment and wisdom is that sure
you know there is a a meditation
protocol for the cultivation of cities
in
tantric hinduism or in vajrayana
buddhism
right where you have these llamas that
develop various
cities or tantricas that you know
cultivate various cities
superpowers as it were but
they do that with nothing close to the
rigor
and exquisite
competence and trainable repeatability
that the cultivation of these latent
human human abilities will have
on the other side of the spectral
revolution and that
really adequate scientific empirical
grasp uh of you know telepathy
clairvoyance psychokinesis
that's going to come from grappling with
these phenomena in the course of ai
research or genetic engineering research
is just on a whole other level than
what's been achieved
uh you know through the course of
various you know
mystical paths to enlightenment you know
in the east um
and so you know i i would say that
to go back to the faustian and faustian
futurism
that in a way you know um although it is
a kind of devil's bargain
it's the faustian path toward
enlightenment
that actually is going to allow us to
delve most deeply
into the hidden capacities you know of
the human spirit
let's unpack this in more detail
relate to us the
relationship between the faustian
futurist
prometheism spectral revolution
unpack that in more detail for us yeah
well
so the spectral revolution again is the
idea that you know we are going to
move beyond materialistic mechanistic
reductionistic science
we're going to move beyond a science
that's constrained by
particular paradigms right so i reject
this idea that you know the cartesian
paradigm or whatever you want to call it
you know the modern
mechanistic paradigm of contemporary
science
is going to be rejected in favor of some
new paradigm that
explains telepathy or psychokinesis on
the basis of quantum mechanics
that's an overly reductive way of
thinking about it
it's not like you can use quantum
mechanics to explain
parapsychology it's that telepathy and
psychokinesis and clairvoyance and so
forth
are consistent with the world that's
described by
quantum physics you'd expect phenomena
like that
in the kind of world that's described by
quantum physics but the promise of
taking the data of parapsychology
seriously is far more than simply
a shift to a new paradigm it's a shift
to post-paradigmatic science that's at
stake here
at being able to think outside of a
commitment to any one box
right not to get rid of the boxes not to
get rid of the atlases or maps of
reality but be able to flip fastly
between them for various practical
purposes there it is and therefore
having even more radical empiricism as
william james would have put it
right and so i think that kind of
radical empiricism
is characteristic of both the faustian
and of the promethean both the figure of
the alchemist faust that goethe
draws from the european middle ages and
the figure of prometheus
you know the titan who uh gives the gift
of technological science to humanity and
who
martyrs himself for the sake of
humanity's liberation from the
tyrannical olympian gods
both of these figures prometheus and
faust
could be seen as emblematic of this kind
of radical empiricism
that i think is the destiny of the west
but there are significant differences
between the two figures
in that faust is the kind of
although you know mary shelley titled
frankenstein the modern prometheus
really frankenstein dr frankenstein is
more a faust-like figure
the faustian figure doesn't care so much
about social welfare
or the good of humanity or general
enlightenment
he's this mad scientist locked up in his
own laboratory attempting to
you know unlock the secrets of the
universe for the sake of his own
empowerment and um
electrification not to say enlightenment
uh to to basically become a lightning
rod
for himself for his own sake and
so there's an egotism there that's not
as characteristic of the promethean
right
the idea of the promethean involves a
humanistic self-sacrifice i mean
prometheus is the first
martyr god in history the
martyr savior of humanity aspects of the
christ figure
are not just prefigured by prometheus
they are
they are well i have to say that
knockoffs
of the promethean christ is aping
prometheus insofar
as he's the savior of humanity right so
there is an
altruism in the figure of prometheus uh
which makes the quest for enlightenment
and for empowerment through
understanding the secrets of nature
inseparable from service to humanity and
inseparable from uplifting of humanity
and liberation ultimately of humanity
from being bound to you know serve
any um
overlords whether they're the promethean
sorry whether they're the olympian
pantheon or whether they're the
the devas of the hindu tradition because
you know the
the olympian pantheon and the uh vedic
pantheon have exactly the same root
they're both
they're both um devolutions of the
primordial aryan pantheon
right and they're not fundamentally
distinct from
each other in their basic qualities
and so the promethean rebellion is a
rebellion against
any kind of uh pantheon that would set
itself over and above humanity against
any kind of divine or heavenly overlords
um and that's an altruistic
mission of service to humanity at large
that kind of
rebellion for the sake of general
liberation
uh is much more characteristic of the
promethean than it is of the faustian
although i'd say again both of these
iterations
of of this archetype of
the god man sage
figure right both of them uh are somehow
emblematic of the radical empiricism
characteristic of western civilization
but i think that the promethean with its
humanistic altruism can be to an extent
an
antidote to the kind of pathological
faustianism that has thus far
dominated the destiny of the west okay
okay let's
table promethean
prometheus being an antidote to some of
the radical
faustian pathology that has developed
from the west as the next thing
this one is on the
in that spectral revolution in the
idea of as is currently being
popularized by
elon musk with neuralink the
idea of being telepathic and all of
these other
both parapsychological phenomena that
you spoke of earlier
as well as in the in the mystic
traditions and then even in the human
development and psychological
development
it's from ego to the
social and ethno and world level and
then you get to these trans-personal and
non-dual
states so
and i love the way that you sort of talk
about on a
even on a on a physics level
even sir roger penrose who won the nobel
prize in physics in 2020
has a cyclic cosmological
theory so even the cutting edge of
physics is now talking about eternity
and cyclicity and these types of things
which is fascinating now to see
that synthesis happening on a quantum
mechanical level
i like how you place in these sort of
neuralink style phenomena right
in a harmonic interplay with that
radical emergence
of physicalism as we see which is really
very
energetic
and also the ability to
shift between these maps
for whatever uses we want is really
cool i'm vibing on that a lot
which are ultimately like layers of the
same
map yeah let me just interject one thing
briefly don't lose your train of thought
please
neurolink is going to run into problems
not in its early stages but the more
um comprehensive this lattice becomes
as it weaves itself into the quantum
computer that's the human brain
uh the more dysfunctional the system is
going to be because it's not taking into
account
what they're going to initially call
anomalous data transfer they're going to
see that telepathy
takes place all the time on a
subconscious level
clairvoyant impressions take place all
the time on a subconscious level people
are reacting to impressions that they
have that they're not consciously
processing
that are not being processed through the
recognized five senses
uh but that are being processed by the
quantum computer that's the brain
and so they're going to be glitches in
in the neural link system the more
advanced
that it it becomes um that are going to
force the engineers
uh that that you know elon musk is uh
you know funding
to look seriously at the same type of
phenomena that parapsychologists have
been studying for a century
i would go out on a limb and predict
that that's going to happen within the
next
15 to 20 years yeah it's inevitable that
in the next
couple of decades that science and
spirituality are going to come
into this much more deep synthesis
and what you just listed is absolutely
present in our day-to-day
where we talk about it on a vibe where
you can
feel the vibe and that
there are so many examples like this
that are going to end up
becoming more and more scientifically
engaged with in a sense it's like a big
edge of knowledge and
planting flags beyond the edge and then
using the scientific method and
synthesize that
with the spiritual mysticism and trying
to get to that flag and
validate it and just doing that yeah and
just to be clear you know i'm not
saying that you know neurolink is going
to run into these problems from the
perspective of a luddite
who wants the research program to fail
and for
these spiritual capacities of mankind to
prevail over mechanical technology no no
what's going to happen is
they're going to iron out the problems
by taking parapsychology data seriously
and you're going to have technologically
augmented telepathy that's going to be
the end result of it
and so now would probably be a good time
to say that
where you have a style of
pretty hardcore you've talked about this
before
as a breakaway civilization
where there's a
a bifurcation of the haves and the
have-nots
and the haves go off into the
singularity meanwhile the have-nots
suffer
and in this case it would be that
would it be that then prometheism is
trying to get
the the roots
of which we are
collectively harmonizing on to be of the
greatest ethics and morals
and wisdoms so that we can all
enter into the singularity or the
recursion
yeah prometheus is an attempt to make
sure that there isn't this
um radical bifurcation of human society
uh
and that there isn't an attempt made to
disempower humanity at large
and the way i see the breakaway
civilization is as an elite
of corporatists military industrialists
people in intelligence
increasingly people in the big tech
world who have reached the conclusion
that humanity at large
is neither prepared for the
technological singularity nor for the
spectral revolution
and so they're going to maintain a
monopoly on singularity level
technologies
which as i suggested earlier these
technologies are going to force
uh us to go through the spectral
revolution if their pursuit to their
combination
right and so they want to maintain a
monopoly on singularity level
technologies
and take them out of the public domain
by engaging in a
controlled demolition of industrial
society a program of deliberate
de-industrialization of the planet
and the establishment of a neo-feudal uh
form of culture on this earth okay with
themselves as the feudal lords
and so you know look
it's a tall order for us to prove them
wrong because
if you look at the state of society
today i think a very strong case can be
made that people are neither prepared
for the technological singularity nor
for the spectral revolution
right so defeating the breakaway
civilization
is about demonstrating um that
there are at least significant groups of
people
who are capable of
presenting an achievable vision of
social reorganization that will allow us
to constructively navigate
both the achievement of
singularity-level technologies in a way
that won't compromise
human individuality and creativity and
also to navigate the spectral revolution
to navigate the recognition mainstream
scientific recognition of esp
psychokinesis without winding up with
something like the salem witch burnings
again and
mass hysteria you know where your
neighbor is accusing you of hexing
uh your family and so and so forth so
that sounds like something we can get
behind yes
yeah so that's the program of prometheus
yes
in a nutshell yes
okay so the the components are
that we have a
singularity level technologies emerging
and to benevolently
on behalf of the whole
share in that abundance while not
sacrificing the individual
and the creativity well for that to
happen we need an evolutionary leap to
take place
and unpack that for us yeah
evolution always
involves selection
and selection against evolution is a
harvest
right i mean in nature nature is is
brutal
and so we are reaching a point where
we're capable of self-directed evolution
where instead of natural selection
there's artificial selection taking
place
and prometheusism is
a way of thinking that's opposed to some
occulted elite being the arbiters of
selection
and self-selecting a group of
corporatists military industrialists and
so forth to have a monopoly on these
technologies and these techniques
when we talk about psychical cultivation
right
and then shutting the rest of humanity
from out of that development
and in fact putting humanity back out to
pasture
as cattle effectively in a neo-agrarian
neo-feudal society
that they looked down on from olympus
okay
like you know that film elysium i don't
know if you saw that worse than that
though
worse than that a world where we've been
completely de-industrialized
and we're maintained effectively as a
farm
so in order for that not to happen
we need to prove ourselves we being
planetary humanity
need to prove ourselves capable of an
evolutionary leap
and we have a very limited time horizon
for that
the one thing i agree with kurzweil's
crowd about is the time frame for the
technological singularity i disagree
with
a lot of their materialism and
reductionism but i agree in terms of the
time frame of the singularity and again
achieving the technological singularity
or coming very close to it will trigger
the spectral revolution
so we have about 30 years to get this
straight okay
it's going to have to happen in this
century and that's an evolutionary
pressure that kind of
constrained time frame given the type of
transformation that has to take place on
a social and an individual level
that's an evolutionary selection
pressure even though
it's now artificial rather than natural
uh and so what has to happen is a
mutation and an evolutionary leap
humanity has to mutate into a kind of
superhumanity okay
like the x-men that has to happen
if that doesn't happen the breakaway
civilization is justified
they're justified i will rest my case
okay so either humanity proves itself
and
again evolution is a selective process
so
there is the mutation which is selected
for
and then that mutation becomes the
matrix for a new form of life
and then there are those who are
selected against
and that's called extinction so what
we're facing is the extinction of
humanity
and the evolutionary leap into a
superhuman form of life
what we need to do before we get to the
point
where you know we take that leap
is we need to to think very deeply about
what it is about humanity that we want
to preserve what are those
characteristics
of humanity that really presage the
superhuman
that are in effect um
uh frederick myers the the psychical
researcher called them pre-versions
they're the opposite of atavisms
they're characteristics of a future form
of life
that you see presaged in an earlier form
of life that hasn't really
made the evolutionary leap yet into that
next
uh stage of biological development
are sort of latent structures that
reflect a future morphology it's like
the the characteristics of the butterfly
that you already see in the caterpillar
so if individuality creativity our
impulse for innovation and so forth
individuation
are really characteristics of the
butterfly that we haven't become yet
that we already see in the caterpillar
we want to make sure that as we develop
artificial
intelligence and as we're capable of
re-engineering the whole human genome we
don't lose those
characteristics that we cherish about
humanity and that in fact
those defining traits are the ones that
are amplified
through this evolutionary leap
what would be our
main
signals that are indicating
to us that a
breakaway civilization is
looming and that there
is a x-men style evolutionary leap
that has to happen in order for the
fruits of that technological
singularity to be maximized and shared
yeah i'm not sure exactly what you mean
in the way that you formulated the
question if you mean
what okay because there's two questions
potentially packed into that
uh one question the way i hear it uh
seems to be what's the evidence for a
breakaway civilization
the other question is um what is the
evidence for
the fact that there needs to be an
evolutionary leap let me take the second
one first
because that just requires a reiteration
of what i what i've already said
and actually then it's probably unneeded
because i also
understand that the evolutionary leap
regardless
is something that is beautiful and it's
something that
is again following a timeline of just a
couple of decades here
of the increasing technologization of
the planet
and the augmentation of the
humanoid to a level that is
unparalleled and so that is clear yeah
there's an acceleration and convergence
of technological developments
that all have the potential to
fundamentally alter the basic parameters
of human existence
into something that is no longer
humanity as we understand it and so now
the questions merge in the sense of
what's
then that now the breakaway civilization
evidence yeah that
that that evolutionary leap
is to counter right the breakaway
civilization
idea as an idea is that
okay so this is an important start the
fact that you say that this is an idea
we could say two things yeah
first of all let's just take it as an
idea to begin with okay right
the idea of a breakaway civilization
with respect to the technological
singularity and the spectral revolution
is that
given how economy and industry
and the intelligence aspects of the
government
are structured right where you have
long-term planning in corporations
much more long-term planning than you do
in government and where you have
uh significant foresight in the
intelligence community right i mean the
nsa's computers are about 30 years ahead
in terms of their processing power than
what's in the public sphere and have
been consistently
this gives them tremendous projective
power so the idea of the breakaway
civilization is that
an elite of corporatists industrialists
people in intelligence
would have seen this coming and they
would have prepared for it
right and what would be their incentive
to just hoard
the benefits of the technological
singularity to protect themselves from a
general collapse and descent into
violent chaos
as in the 8 billion are not ready as
they're not ready they're going to tear
themselves apart and they're going to
tear us apart in the process and we have
vested interests
and so to protect our interests like a
compulsive
fear-based thinking yes and so i'm
calling for us to resist that the eight
billion
i don't like this way of thinking and i
don't want these people to be the
arbiters of the destiny of humanity
okay that having been said if we prove
incapable of that evolutionary leap
their thinking will have been justified
okay and to prove capable of the
evolutionary leap
is to right now that's the idea of a
breakaway civilization
the empirical case for a breakaway
civilization
you know is is something that i mean the
proof is in the pudding you have to
really lay it out and
in um an essay i wrote
called black sunrise which was published
in my anthology lovers of sophia
i present evidence for
a
secret industrial development program
that extends into a secret space program
from the time that the uh
basically brain trust of nazi germany
was imported into the united states
through project paperclip
that in 1947 when you know the central
intelligence agency which was by the way
co-constituted
uh through absorbing the entire nazi
germany
uh eastern european spy network when the
cia brought all these thousands of nazi
scientists
into the united states not just rocket
scientists as we're often led to believe
but
all kinds of social engineers and
psychologists and so forth
um and when the corporatists who were
funding the third reich
from north america people like ford and
the carlisles and the asters and the
rockefellers
you know rockefeller uh you also gave
evidence for jp morgan
rockefeller and j.p morgan were the
principal financiers of nazi germany
from out of new york
so what i argue in black sunrise and
then expand upon in prometheism
is that beginning in 1947
you had this military industrial
corporate
culture develop
uh within the black projects of the
united states
that ultimately spawned a civilization
in its own right
which considers itself distinct from
not just western civilization but
terrestrial civilization at large
and has developed a very elitist uh
mentality okay they're extremely
alienated
from the planetary society at large and
they intend to
secure their own survival and their own
interests um
and you know people often refer to this
as the military industrial complex in
the united states what they don't
understand is that
it's not really american it is
uh fundamentally constituted by imported
uh german national socialists um and and
a few
other people from axis power countries
italians and so forth
but this this thing was basically
imported lock stock and barrel
from germany and it has extended its
tentacles throughout
the military industrial corporate and
intelligence world
i would argue that the deepest part of
what today is referred to as the deep
state
is really this breakaway civilization
and that it has
evolved if we want to use that word or
let's just say developed
not to use the word evolved right it has
developed to the point where
it has an independent base of economic
productivity
uh and industrial development probably
off planet as well probably on the moon
and in other places beyond the earth
involving propulsion technologies
that have been kept out of the public
sphere and let me just make a side note
here
with respect to propulsion technologies
this is another aspect of the
technological singularity
that calls for a dramatic and
rapid transformation of human psychology
um
you can take the same engine that
produces
anti-gravity a zero point energy drive
that produces uh a
local gravitational field and allows for
the type of propulsion
that we see in unidentified flying
objects you can take that same
engine and you can turn it into a bomb
far more destructive than the worst
thermonuclear weapon it would become an
implosion device a kind of
uh con a an artificially produced
singularity
on the surface of the earth which would
have a destructive force far greater
than that of any nuclear weapon right
so yes it's true that you could put one
of these generators in everybody's
backyard and we would all have free
energy and we would be beyond fossil
fuel and
you know you could have you know
jetson's cars that are
hovering through the air with
anti-gravity technologies zipping
through the skies of all of our cities
but anyone can use
artificial intelligence and his trusty
robot in his
in in his garage to make the necessary
modifications
to this engine to transform it into a
bomb that can wipe out an entire
continent
right i mean this is the kind of dual
use that we've had a problem with in
terms of nuclear energy
throughout the 20th century the
potential for misuse here
is of an another order of magnitude
altogether
uh it's far more dangerous than turning
a nuclear power
plant into the basis for development of
a nuclear weapon
uh so and it's much easier to do and the
technology will be much more ubiquitous
and the know-how to transform
that energy device into a weapon will
also be much more ubiquitous so
again until and unless we can make this
evolutionary leap
as cynical as it may sound the breakaway
civilization is entirely justified
in concealing this kind of propulsion
technology
is there a
a bit of darwinian metaphysics
that is at play here that well to hell
with darwin i mean
you know darwin only co-developed the
theory of evolution with alfred wallace
alfred wallace
was a co-developer of the theory of
evolution and wallace
did not dismiss the spiritual let's say
a selection
at the metaphysical level yeah yeah i
would i would say so
so and so that's what's at stake yeah
okay
so it's fascinating because
about six months ago or so
i was so fascinated with selection
at the metaphysical level at this
universal level
and
i'm still very fascinated with it
yet my
my satori around non-duality
especially has made it
a lot more
chill sure
as in
we are eternal and it continues
yeah i wouldn't bank on that
and the
you have to define who the wii is there
when you make that kind of statement
well
they're in a sense the
the breakaway civilization
is not separate from the
absolute then the
7.9 billion that are not
part of that look does that make sense
yeah no absolutely look
if you let's let's put it this way if
you want to say
that by doing this the breakaway
civilization will go against the dao
and this is not good because you know
this is like when you stand up against
the water
in in the dalton chain right you know
there's something that stands firm in an
ossified calcified way
will be shattered by an oncoming wave
right
um if the breakaway civilization is
turning against the dao
when it bifurcates humanity in this way
and you know engages in a controlled
demolition of industrial civilization on
this planet puts us all back out to
pasture
well sure maybe the dow will catch up
with them eventually i don't want to
have to wait
3 000 years or 30 000 years to see
the interstellar civilization that they
found based on this kind of a mistake
ultimately collapse it may collapse
it may be disharmonious it may be built
on a fundamental disharmony
on an achilles heel that ultimately
leads to its demise
i would rather prevent that whole
devolution from taking place
and if i
may also provide another framework that
is multi-layered to see how it resonates
in the most absolute sense everything is
already
indescribable perfection
in the most absolute sense
we already are perfect whole complete
unconditionally free that's a very
consoling thought
it's one more layer yeah
the next layer is a very dualistic
concession to that non duel which is
that
there are very clearly uh
a yin and yang that are in flux
in an ascension towards an attractor
and that in this case we could in the
story
portray the breakaway civilization as
that dark
and that these 7.9 billion taking this
evolutionary leap as the light
and the
also in that dualistic concession is the
suffering and the well-being so in the
non-dual
layer is an indescribable perfection
where that duality doesn't exist
and in the dualistic concession is where
they're suffering and there's well-being
where you describe how the
evolutionary leap enables
the ut most utopian
style flourishing abundance well-being
prosperity for all right
thumbs-ups yeah now for that ladder to
be achievable
the former has to be rejected that's
what i would present to you
is that what i would submit to you is
that the sense of equanimity that comes
from this sense that everything is
already perfect
that has to be rejected in order for
this utopian transformation of society
to be something that we strive for and
that's what's differentiated the west
from the east throughout the course of
history
and i would further add that
the kinds of subtle states of mind that
for example gotama buddha
describes in in the form that we get in
the tripitaka
in the the oldest sermons that are
attributable to gautama
when he goes into descriptions of of
subtle states of mind
that are able to perceive
the co-dependent arising of all
phenomena and able to see through the
illusion of the self
right because in buddhism i mean this is
a
really complex uh you know
mind-boggling idea that although there's
rebirth there's no self that
you know the strands of the persona are
being rewoven from lifetime to lifetime
without any indestructible core
that would be eternal right so i think
that
what you're inclined to describe as an
eternal perfection
is a projection it's a it is a
psychological moral projection
valuation that you are
coloring a much more
complex and ineffable uh experience with
okay the the experience that you're
projecting onto when you describe
the infinite perfection of the present
moment is the experience
of what gotama called codependent
origination
and no self and you know this is where
the big break happened between
buddhism and hinduism is in this
critique that gotama leveled
both at the idea of an imperishable
eternal self
and at the idea of a cosmic
consciousness
that's abiding and perfect namely
brahman so
you know buddha i think very rightly
deconstructs
this mirroring of the atman and the
brahman and says that both of these are
projections
onto something that is truly ineffable
unfathomable okay and that that
i don't want to call it a thing that no
thing
i mean that's the nothingness the
shunyata the no thing-ness that
no thingness that which is ungraspable
is a state that the mind is
introspectively capable of entering
because our minds are quantum phenomena
and it's the nature of quantum
physical processes that we are
proprioceptively experiencing
in that state your description of it as
uh perfection in the present moment or
infinite perfection or
you know what's eternally
beautiful or complete is a is a human
moral projection
onto it it's a moralistic human
projection onto it which
gives you a sense of tranquility and uh
groundedness um and buddha i think
rightly
tried to take that ground out from under
people
okay um and and make them enter the void
and i am very much aligned with him on
that
um and i think that it's interesting
when you look at martin heidegger's
thought you know the last great thinker
in the trajectory of western philosophy
you see that heidegger's meditations on
nothingness
very closely converge with what the
buddha is saying with the huge
difference being that the primary
concern of heidegger's philosophical
thought
was understanding the essence of
technological science
so that trajectory where you know
heidegger's meditations on nothingness
converge with
buddha's deconstruction of substance and
and the permanent and the eternal
that convergence between the east and
the west is i think
exactly where we need to go uh you know
in the
in in the intellectual and spiritual
sphere as we try to navigate the
technological singularity in the
spectral revolution successfully
one of the core things that came up
there
was that this
agentless attributeless
metaphysical zero absolute
is
it just is and this is the appearance
sure that's a horrifying experience
though if you've ever actually had that
experience
it's not really consoling it makes it
consoling
i completely disagree my
my take on it is that that
is the
piercing of the veil
to the source that
enables the absolute highest morality
to channel through
and so that
inward path whether it be the
atma vichara the self-abiding or whether
it be the parable of the prodigal son
or any of these again very perennial
wisdoms
of going all the way inward to the
source
it creates a very natural way
effortless action
in all of the tantric path that sahaja
samadhi where you weave
your realizations into the
social fabric of the dream of the
illusion of the appearance
now i purposely gave these layers
where there's the most non-dual layer
and then there's the layer that is the
dualistic concession
and in doing so it paints
a landscape that is
true simultaneity in a sense
and i
definitely feel and resonate with
how you say that in the dualism
to completely reject the non-dual
makes this hyper awareness towards
the absolute architecting toward the
light
that evolutionary leap that's needed yet
at the same time i recognize that what
is
most true in that simultaneity
is the non-dual and also what is
true is that when the
piercing of the veil to the source
occurs the natural
flow
just like with me and so many others
is a effortless action a wu way
that comes through to do those light
architectures
that are needed in that dualistic
concession to make that evolutionary
leap
that then makes a much more harmonic
technological singularity
how do does that make sense yeah i
understand what you're saying
uh i think that
it does not necessarily follow
from experiencing that sign what you
describe to simultaneity
it does not necessarily follow that
you will live a life
you could characterize as wu way
and that that kind of
attitude fundamental attitude um
is the only one that's going to be able
to allow us to successfully navigate the
technological singularity in fact
i would go so far as to suggest that an
overemphasis of that kind of an attitude
which again doesn't
necessarily follow from a direct
experience of what you're calling
simultaneity
that kind of attitude could be really
deleterious and
you know there's a reason why chinese
civilization did not lead to the
technological singularity
and it's probably related to the reason
why chinese civilization should not be
allowed to
determine the
ways in which we design policies that
allow us to avoid
the most dangerous pitfalls um that we
could face in the course of
the technological singularity uh you
know
this is why again i reach back to
prometheus as an archetype
i agree with martin heidegger that the
solution has to come from out of
the problem um that the pro the the
problem the challenge that we face
the challenge that western man has
forced the rest of the planet to face
through this world and framing world
colonizing technological science
that challenge cannot be
adequately addressed from out of the
metaphysical resources
of uh another culture or civilization
it has to be transformed in its own
essence and so
we have to go back to the promethean
fountainhead of technological science
in order to bring about an inversion and
a reorientation
of the techno scientific from
a mindset that's based on
instrumentalization
on domineering control into a mindset
that expresses that other dimension of
techne that the greeks understood
namely oasis or poetic creation
creativity
uh the kind of innovation that's
inseparable from the arts
and you know you see this
complementarity of techne
as technical control and techne as
poetry in effect
in all of the great uh renaissance men
throughout the course of the history of
science and of the arts you know all the
way from leonardo da vinci to nikola
tesla
so this is one of the reasons why i
reached back to the promethean because i
don't think that the wu way attitude
is what is going to save us from
some of the most horrific prospects um
intrinsic
to this evolutionary moment in our
history
i think we need to transform the the
salvation the salvific force has to come
from out of the danger
okay it it has to come from the same
matrix
the same metaphysical ontological matrix
that
gave rise to western technological
science
and it may it may very well
be a idea
that there is a breakaway civilization
and that there is a evolutionary leap
that
needs to happen as in it could
very well be just a natural
harmonic unfolding that is happening
that is i don't think that's fair to say
because it's not it on an aesthetic
level
in terms of aesthetic judgment in terms
of you know describing the
characteristics of something
and painting a picture of what's going
on in our history
i don't think that's a fair statement to
say because
uh there are moments both in geological
and in biological history where there
are dramatic ruptures
uh there you know not everything is a
steady progression in nature in
fact nature is is catastrophic nature is
punctuated by catastrophes and and so is
evolution as a biological process if you
understand yourself
as eternal
then what
at this moment is lacking
everything everything is lacking yeah
because that conception is so vacuous
that everything is lacking
if you understand yourself as eternal in
the sense that
through that understanding you are
completely satisfied
and achieve total equanimity so that you
don't strive for anything
see but that's not the that's not what
happens it's not a
it's not an the middle path or the
middle way or the tantric path or sahaja
samadhi or the goldilocks zone any of
these
understandings is all about taking
what happens when you go all the way to
your source and it's a very
natural look i understand exactly
towards those light architectures that
we're talking about as in
this expression of source is not going
to
stop it's not going to stop suddenly
undergoing the process of bringing these
biggest questions to los
angeles and doing these other media
projects
around the enlightenment and the
awakening of civilization it's not just
going to stop because
ah non-duality fantastic now i do
nothing
right that's that's a very straw man
perspective on the per unknown
and that's not what i'm saying at all
it's a middle way right
and so therefore if nothing is lacking
right now and if that is ever
much is lacking right now it and that's
we're terribly lacking
it's beautiful society is lacking we're
lacking on an individual level
this conditions are unacceptable and
jason they're unacceptable this is it
where on the most non-dual perspective
it's nothing is lacking it's perfection
on the second
level of the dualism there is the
there's suffering there's all these
sustainable development goals that we
want to make
there is this we want to make this
evolutionary
we turn that completely on its head i
would turn that completely on its head
and say that on some on some zombies
prioritizing the selection at the
metaphysical level is what you would say
you prioritize selection at the
metaphysical level because
you have a prioritization of telling the
story about
it's a priority in terms of the
dimensions of human experience
okay first of all i hear what you're
saying okay and likewise
much much more than much more than a
description of it as wu way
i studied for some time the zogchen
teachings in tibetan buddhism
and this teaching of the the doctrine of
the great perfection to me is the
clearest example of what you're talking
about
but you have to understand that the
zogchen llamas in tibet
made common cause with the ss the ss
went to tibet and heinrich himmler had a
good working relationship with
zogchen llamas who were totally prepared
to ally in a military effort against the
chinese with nazi germany
okay and even if you read the biography
of padma sambhava
and look at how he lived his life as a
warrior and a conqueror
and the kinds of ceremonies he performed
in cremation grounds okay and in
cemeteries in the middle of the night
there is no uh
moral conclusion that you can draw
from an experience of perfection in the
sense in which you are defining it or
the zogen teachings
define it all of that is a projection
that projection is influenced by
individual psychology
by cultural heritage so on and so forth
all right
i don't deny that there is this fair as
somebody that studied
the perennial wisdoms across those
mystic traditions i'm just surprised
that
it's being voiced as a as a
psychological projection of some sort
rather than just a one end no no i i'm
not saying that the experience is a
projection
i'm saying that the way in which you're
characterizing its implications for how
we live our lives and
how it you believe can be constructive
for society and for social development
that that's a projection onto a very
real experience
that can be had an experience of no self
and experience of i would say
quantum superposition not to call it
simultaneity but
an experience of uh the world
beyond chronological time beyond the
limits of sequential chronological time
right because we live in a world of
quantum superposition
where uh you know the future doesn't
follow the past in a sequential way and
it's possible for the mind to experience
that
but there are no moral uh implications
that
necessarily follow from that type of
experience
and so if we want a better society we
have to strive for one
the reason why people say that god or
self-realization
is the most important service that you
can render humanity ramana maharshi and
many others
is because what that does is it makes it
so that when i look at
jason or when i look at naseem or when i
look at
anybody what happens is i see god
i see the self i see the oneness the
sourceness
so well that's good but you can do that
while you drive a samurai sword through
somebody
i would never hurt my own body
right it makes me no i i totally
disagree look i mean
you should look at you should look at
some of the you should look at some of
the
the zen masters who participated in the
japanese war effort in the second world
war
right uh some of the greatest japanese
zen masters who were on the battlefields
in manchuria and so forth in the second
world war
um to understand how somebody like that
and somebody like padma zambaba who
literally
you know drove swords through people and
you know filled them with arrows out of
his quiver okay
from rooftops how it's entirely possible
to look
right into somebody's eyes and
understand not only
that he is not separate from you but
that neither of you really have any self
as you drive the sword through the
person's solar plexus
to me to me there's a diamond of wisdom
there and
that may also
be a
a story that indicates
something unique and special to the
contribution
of the conversation and collective
absolutely also that
the simultaneity
where there's a recognition of
all these layers that we've been talking
about happening
where there is a perspective of a
breakaway civilization the perspective
of
the quantum leap or the evolutionary
leap that needs to happen in order to
maximize prosperity into the
technological singularity
while simultaneously everything is
it just is and i love
being able to hold that simultaneity
and that's sort of what you could say is
like synthesis level consciousness or
joseph in the code of many colors level
consciousness
is where you take in these eight billion
hermeneutics
of truth and you hold them all
simultaneously yeah
in what's happening yeah look i think
deconditioning the mind periodically is
a great thing to do
and one of the reasons why i chose
prometheus
as a an archetypal symbol for
uh the movement that i'm trying to
launch
is because prometheus is not an
all-knowing and an all-powerful god
prometheus is a deity among other
deities and
in a prometheus society there's
certainly a place
for the buddhist path to enlightenment
there's certainly a place for
tantric yoga right and i think that it's
necessary
to decondition the mind using these
types of practices periodically
but i don't think that should be done at
the expense
of a promethean striving for utopia for
a radical transformation of society
and for the call you know the
furtherance of human evolution
in my understanding they don't happen
separately from one another but together
as one again like i said it's necessary
sometimes to decondition the mind
especially if you're involved in this
kind of titanic
promethean striving uh you know
on occasion it's good to remind yourself
that you don't really exist
jesus has been such a great convo i
super appreciate you this has been
fascinating on
so many dimensions i'm just so grateful
i agree a lot of dynamic tension those
are the best conversations
yeah yeah yeah a lot of the the tennis
ball hitting back and forth was just
really strong and and
episode one hopefully of of many
unpacking this
yeah would be my pleasure we would love
to have you back for more
yeah you feel satisfied like good time
to to wrap
yeah yeah yeah absolutely solid and yeah
this is super solid we've reached the
culmination
as we are in uh as what we've described
as well
wow beautiful not a convergence but a
comment yes
i love it all right thank you thanks
everybody for tuning in we greatly
appreciate you
what an epic convo on metaphysics
geopolitics
so many things so many things
find the links in the bio below
jasonrezajorjani.com
you can support him there across all of
his books
also across joining him on a
donation subscription so that he can
continue
doing his work
prometheism.com as well his twitter
profile
and also all of his books on amazon you
can go and find those there
like the video if it brought you value
subscribe if you haven't already
and let us know how you feel in the
comments below
about all that bigness that was
discussed we'd love to hear from you
and
simultane simultaneously
pierce the veil to your source and build
that
more abundant and prosperous future as
we enter into that technological
singularity
we love you very much thank you for
tuning in thank you again jason
been my pleasure alan thank you thank
you we'll see you soon everyone
peace